Apple has invested
573 billion dollars into this over the
past 10 years can you guess what this is
maybe r d well Apple spends about six to
seven billion dollars per quarter on R D
so while that adds up to about 250
billion over a 10-year period that's
less than half of this other investment
maybe they spend it on Acquisitions well
Apple only has two Acquisitions that
even cross the billion dollar Mark beats
and Intel smartphone modem business so
nowhere near 573 billion maybe they've
just been hoarding a crap ton of cash
while Apple has actually been decreasing
their cash reserves consistently from
over a hundred billion dollars down to
just over 50 billion
okay then maybe it's the total value of
all of Apple's assets well while Apple's
assets do Tower at an impressive 350
billion dollars it still Falls over 200
billion short of 573 billion but then if
Apple didn't spend this money on R D
Acquisitions cash reserves or
Investments where the hell did such a
ginormous amount of money go well it
turns out that Apple's biggest bet over
the past 10 years is actually stock
BuyBacks that's right Apple has spent
573 billion dollars over the past 10
years on stock BuyBacks for perspective
that's enough money to buy a fortune 10
company cash in second place we have a
Microsoft who comes in at a measly 170
billion over the past 10 years or over
400 billion dollars less it looks like
this disparity is only going to grow
larger as apple is simply doubling down
in fact nowadays apple is spending
nearly a hundred billion dollars on
stock BuyBacks every single year
assuming that this continues to increase
Apple will spend over a trillion dollars
on BuyBacks over the next 10 years this
has sparked rumors regarding whether
apple is trying to go private
but more importantly it has raised
concerns about whether this is healthy
for the economy instead of investing
this money into creating new products
creating new jobs or even just storing
it in cash or bonds where it can be lent
out Apple has decided to spend half a
trillion dollars on inflating their
stock price so here's the story of how I
once banned a practice became so popular
and why companies are throwing it
trillions at BuyBacks every single year
thank you
the reasoning behind why companies love
stock BuyBacks is not rocket science by
purchasing shares from the market and
the burning them companies are not only
adding demand to the market but they're
also reducing Supply so thanks to basic
supply and demand economics this Dynamic
leads to stock prices going up aside
from boosting the stock price BuyBacks
also boost the benefits of being a
shareholder for example let's say that
apple had a total of 100 shares of stock
and that you owned 10 of them this means
that you own 10 of the company but what
if Apple came in and eliminated 20 of
these shares by buying them back well
you still only own 10 shares but since
the total number of shares has decreased
to 80 you now own 12 and a half percent
of Apple this means that you'll now get
12 and a half percent of the dividends
12 and a half percent of the voting
power and so on and so forth so it's no
wonder why companies and shareholders
love BuyBacks but the impact of buybacks
on the economy is not so bright this is
why stock BuyBacks were banned for over
50 years up until 1981. you see it the
idea of companies buying back their own
stock is by no means a new one it's only
natural that once a company runs out of
external places to invest they turn to
investing in themselves but ironically
the roots of BuyBacks actually Trace
back to times of Despair as opposed to
times of prosperity to the Great
Depression a lot of activists who are
not fan of BuyBacks like to claim that
stock BuyBacks are what led to the Great
Depression in the first place but this
is not true the primary reasons for the
Great Depression were simply excessive
speculation paired with excessive levels
of debt but while BuyBacks did not cause
the depression the Depression Did cause
BuyBacks and the BuyBacks only made the
depression worse for obvious reasons
investors became frantic when the Dow
Jones crashed 90 within a matter of
three years they demanded that
Executives put up strong core early
reports increased dividends and
basically defy the economic situation
understandably this was simply not
possible for most companies given the
economic landscape but what they were
able to do was provide investors some
Solace through BuyBacks
but this didn't not change the fact that
most investors were down a ridiculous
amount it did ensure that they could
maximize the wealth that they did still
have
so BuyBacks quickly became the go-to way
to Pander to shareholders during the
depths of the Great Depression but this
was terrible for the economy to escape
the depression America needed
corporations to invest in employees
factories and r d but instead companies
were spending the little money they did
have on superficial Avenue this went on
for a couple of years until the
Securities Act of 1933 and the
Securities Exchange Act of 1934. this
legislation wasn't targeted at stock
BuyBacks specifically in fact it doesn't
even mention BuyBacks rather it was
designed to prevent the depression from
happening again by putting some checks
and balances in place one of these
checks and balances was that companies
were not allowed to manipulate their own
stock price technically there was no
mention of stock BuyBacks so that wasn't
more of a gray area but no company was
brave enough to test the SEC so the
practice of stock BuyBacks simply
disappeared into Oblivion and would have
been great if it stayed that way but
that obviously wasn't the case
foreign
decades no one even mentioned the idea
of stock BuyBacks the entire world was
in recovery mode both from the Great
Depression and World War II America was
also super focused on showing up the
USSR with capitalism so allowing
corporations to inefficiently spend
their reserves on BuyBacks was out of
the question but as the stock market
blew past its pre-depression highs and
America landed people on the moon
Congress became a lot more relaxed they
were no longer out to prove something
they had already come out on top so now
they were able to focus on personal
gaining and what's the easiest way to
make money as a politician well the
answer is to align yourself with the
richest business people and corporations
around the world this coincided with yet
another economic disaster the inflation
crisis of the 1970s in the early 1970s
President Nixon would end the gold
standard meaning that US dollars were no
longer backed by gold this led inflation
spiraling out of control the stock
market stagnating and interest rates
rising to a painful 19 so when President
Ronald Reagan stepped in and suggested
doubling down on capitalism people were
more receptive than ever the logic was
that capitalism is what saved America
from the Great Depression and made
America into a world power so if we
wanted to get back on track we should
just let capitalism do its magic with
that President Reagan would enact a slew
of pro-capitalist legislation act now
known as a Reaganomics this included
things like slashing personal income tax
from 70 down to 28 percent reducing
corporate tax from 48 down to 34 percent
and easing regulation substantially one
of these regulation reducing moves was
ruled 10b-18 introduced by the SEC in
1982 as you may have already guessed
this rule created a safe harbor for
stock BuyBacks as long as companies
abided by four stipulations these
stipulations governed when where and how
companies were allowed to buy back stock
but complying with these rules is
actually completely voluntary as we
previously touched on the SEC never
actually outright the ban stock BuyBacks
so companies could still try to push the
limit and buy back stock without the
following these stipulations but given
that they're pretty easy stipulations to
follow no one has really ever pushed the
boundaries and with that stock BuyBacks
were officially legal once again but the
practice didn't catch on as quickly as
you might expect you see it back in the
1980s value investing was way more
popular than growth investing and one of
the key attributes that value investors
were looking for was a strong and
increasing dividend so whenever
companies had extra cash lying around
they far prefer to just pay out larger
dividends than buy back stock not to
mention companies used to have much more
modest profit margins of 10 to
so they couldn't meaningfully buy back a
substantial portion of the company
anyway but all of this would change with
the rise of tech
over time the mentality of Corporations
and shareholders slowly shifted and that
this is beautifully documented by
statements from The Business Roundtable
which is a coalition of top CEOs in 1981
this was the purpose of Corporations as
defined by these CEOs corporations have
a responsibility first of all to make
available to the public quality goods
and services at the fair prices
thereby earning a profit that attracts
Investments to continue it and enhance
the Enterprise provide jobs and build
the economy but by 1997 this was the new
purpose of Corporations as defined by
these CEOs the principal objective of a
business Enterprise is to generate
economic returns to its owners if the
CEO and the directors are not focused on
shareholder value it may be less likely
the corporation will realize that value
this Probably sounds familiar as this is
how companies are run today the sole
purpose of most companies and Executives
today is to serve shareholders as best
as possible so stock BuyBacks started
looking more and more favorable but
again no company could afford to spend
it tens if not hundreds of billions on
stock BuyBacks until apple or actually
more specifically the iPhone Apple
didn't instantly turn to stock BuyBacks
either though for the first five years
after the launch of the iPhone they
added plenty of expenses regarding
scaling production marketing and r d but
by 2013 Apple had achieved a pretty
strong financial position leading to
their first stock buyback Apple was by
no means shy they didn't start off with
the modest one or two billion dollar
buyback they went straight for a 10
billion stock buyback in 2012. and less
than 12 months later they would announce
a record-breaking stock buyback of 60
billion dollars
and that was it from then on out Apple
has been the Undisputed king of stock
BuyBacks pouring in tens of billions
into BuyBacks every single year all of
this brings up the question is Apple
trying to go private and is that even
possible well with Apple's market cap
ballooning to 2-3 trillion dollars it's
becoming less and less possible but in
the late 2010s it was very much possible
in fact in 2017 Apple was on track to
buy back 50 of itself by 2020. so going
private was not Out Of Reach per se but
this was never part of the plan you see
it when Apple buys back shares they're
not putting these shares in some sort of
company treasury rather they're burning
the shares and removing it from the
supply so the shares that apple is
buying back are basically being donated
to all shareholders in proportion to
their ownership
so with that being said apple is by no
means going private and that is just a
myth
people are often critical of stock
BuyBacks but the reality is that stock
BuyBacks are just the tip of the iceberg
the bigger underlying trend is that the
entire purpose of Corporations is
Shifting originally the purpose of
Corporations was to create a value in
the marketplace while generating a
respectable profit but nowadays the sole
purpose of Corporations is to serve
shareholders no matter the cost stock
BuyBacks are just one example of this
trend but they're by no means the only
issue with that being said though it
doesn't seem like this trend will be
changing anytime soon because that's not
in the executive's best interest you see
as companies engage in stock BuyBacks
Lobby for lower taxes Lobby for Less
regulation and maximize profits
shareholders are much more willing to
pay Executives more and more
back in 1965 the average CEO was paid it
20 times the average worker at the
company
today the average CEO is paid at 399
times the average worker at the same
company so as long as this ratio keeps
increasing it you can bet that apple and
every other company will continue
betting big on stock BuyBacks did you
realize how much Apple has spent on
BuyBacks comment that down below also
drop a like if you think that Apple
makes way too much money
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community suggested video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions actually answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
thank you
[Music]